here are my tips for reducing stress
around taking important tests tip 1
build a habit of practice building a
habit of practice is super valuable I
know I'm guilty of myself if sometimes I
get so caught up with something or I'm
stressed about something that I almost
freeze but it really should be the other
way around I try to remind myself that
Sal if you put time in on a regular
basis if I use things like official SAT
practice to take practice tests
understand my strengths and weaknesses
work on where my weaknesses are and I do
it on a regular basis that's my best
chance of actually improving and we have
studies that show there's a strong
correlation between students who are
able to put in even 6 hours and growing
50% more than expected so I really
encourage you don't get too obsessed
with the outcome but think about what
can I do on a regular basis not all at
once not binge practicing but what I do
on a regular basis day-in day-out
and you'll be really impressed how much
the gains will accumulate tip to share
your feelings one of the things that has
taken me up many years to to discover
the wisdom of and I hope to share it
with you is whatever is going on in your
life that you think is unique to you
it's not it's probably happening in the
minds of everyone else around you even
those people who look perfect on social
media and always seem to have their act
together and their hair perfectly combed
in great grades they're feeling the same
things the same stresses the same
insecurities in their mind they might be
they might even be feeling far more than
what you are and so do yourself a favor
and do them a favor by being vulnerable
and talking about it and talking about
how you can actually support each other
I got to tell you even when I was a
student like you and even today as I try
to navigate my own life by being able to
have a support network people who I can
commiserate with it really helps lower
the stress and that's just going to make
you a healthier person but also the more
relaxed you are entering into these
tests the better you're going to perform
and tip 3 keep a bigger perspective one
thing that some of us adults often
forget is how sometimes stressful the
stage of life you're in is you know us
adults we say oh I got to pay bills I
got to do this I gotta pay the mortgage
but I can guess what's going on in your
mind because I went through it myself
you're saying hey I've got to do really
good on this test because if I do good
on this test then I might be able to
have that opportunity if I do well with
that opportunity I'll get that
opportunity and then my life will be
perfect but if I don't do well well then
that opportunity might happen that
happen and then that opportunity might
not happen and then what will I be who
will I be and what I'd like to tell you
and I'm literally I'm not making this up
I've gotten rejected and I failed at far
more things than you can imagine and
even though in the moment I sometimes
thought all was lost
a week later six months later a year
later I realized that actually it wasn't
that big of a deal and in some ways it
was a blessing because maybe that wasn't
the thing for me and so when you go into
test prep mode yes of course you want to
do as well as you can but that score
isn't you it doesn't define you you are
so much more than that one score you are
so much more than what school you get
into and I'll tell you a secret and this
is you know after being out in the the
real world for for over 20 years I've
actually has haven't seen a big
correlation between where someone
happened to go to school and how
successful they might be and I even did
the successful in air quotes because
what society calls successful money Fame
all of that I got to tell you also does
not correlate with real happiness real
happiness is knowing who you are doing
what you can but not getting obsessed
with outcomes not coveting things not
coveting I must do this I must do that
because no matter how much money you
make or no matter how famous or
accomplished you get if you have that
mindset you'll never be happy but if you
say look I'm gonna be my best self I'm
going to do right by myself and right by
the world and the things will play out
as they see fit then you'll always be
content and you'll actually be far
happier than than most people on this
planet so those are my tips for reducing
stress as you approach these types of
tests and
in general life advice - I hope you take
it to heart take it with a grain of salt
- but I I believe that it might be
really valuable